okay let's set some common historical
background about common 64 because maybe
nobody not all of you knows what we are
speaking about
and okay this is a picture of Commerce
64. in Italy uh where I come from it was
called The Big Biscuit because of the
shape and the the color of the chassis I
don't know if it's the same in other
countries as well but that was the way
and it was one of the first home
computer that born in 1982 together with
apple II and a lot of others it was
mainly based for it used for gaming
actually because of several reasons but
viruses were a thing back then and uh
so they they were existing but it was
very different from the current reality
okay let's start in defining a virus
before going ahead so that we are all on
the same page
okay virus it's a let's say a kind of a
program that without user knowledge try
to persist and replicate I'm sure that
this is not a 100
fitting definition but it's a good
starting point for all of us include
going ahead understanding what we are
speaking about today
okay today if we think about virus or
malicious software we are thinking about
something that is built to give again
the attacker mainly we are speaking
about financial gain or gain of other
type like you know information
harvesting or something like that with
that in any case is going to finish
again at the end but if we think about
the situation back then it was a
completely different thing because there
were no Financial motivation behind the
virus but it was something more done for
a show of technical knowledge really and
not doing something malicious to the
user but pranking people maybe or just
show something that is okay I can do it
so I can show you that I can do it but I
don't want to harm you or whatever yes
or whatever else and that's the reason
why I tend to Define this more close to
the demo scene back then so the demo
scene was the way of
showing
the skills of a programmers doing
graphic sounds and so on and in some way
viruses were something like that they're
done for showing the low level technical
expertise let's say
and you may think that the lack of
financial again behind this may
go to some Nave code a few
functionalities or something written
very bad badly but it's not the case we
will see together that these tiny
programs are really little Jewelers of
programming and
[Music]
um
technical skill set okay let's start
from the state of the art so which are
the virus is known for Commerce 64. this
is the least pretty much complete it's
it sounds pretty funny if you look at it
because we have a uh we count seven
entries here which is more or less what
we can think it's uh it happens in a
minute of malware creation nowadays so
it's really nice to see that there were
so many so so few weird viruses back
then and there are great analysis
already done most of them especially for
BHP which is the first one and
considered to be the first virus is
created for virus for create for common
64 and one of the first virus ever
created
but there is one which is not analyzed
yet it's the Ebola virus
the only thing it's it was in in the
list we saw before here it was the
fourth one and
the only thing that I found around
before starting this kind of analysis
was this little sentence coming from
wikidot.com saying that nothing was
really known about this virus and there
were some things happening when you run
it but it was not clear how it was
replicating and so on and so I decided
to get this one in in order to try to
get
get this back to life I obviously used
some tools and some
things to having meter running again
and these tools we are going to list
them right now are something to do
static analysis which is for example the
the tool you I use for static analysis
gidra I went on tool I'm sure that you
know it with a specific plugin used to
load this common 64 virus I did some
custom scripting for for analyzing the
virus itself with Java and the plugins
of guitar itself I also created a010
editor custom template in order to be
able to analyze the disk images these 64
images are the files representing a disk
e-commerce 64. then I do I do I did also
some um Dynamic analysis obviously and
obviously and I use device Simulator for
doing that by simulator it's an emulator
which has also a very nice debugger in
it and then their Master 3.5 h3s which
is an utility used to manage the 64
images again
a couple of screenshots about uh about
this and this is for example the
screenshot from Vice which is the
emulator I use for dynamic analysis as
you can see on the bottom you see the
common 64 screen and on the top you see
the debugger the debugger it's very well
done it allows you to step into the code
dumping memory dumping op codes and
there is also this little window on top
or right showing you register and also
this Windows showing computer and drive
it remember this because it will be very
important for our analysis so it looks
like we don't have a register just only
on the same on the main CPU and that's
important to remember for our analysis
here then I use guitar as I said okay
this is a well known tool so it was for
static analysis the assembly code it's
also it supports the Commerce 64
architecture which is based on 6502 CPU
it also decompiled the code but in this
case it's not useful to have the code
the compiler to be honest so I just
looked at the raw assembly code
then here we have the custom template a
custom template I created for zero one
zero editor which allows me to
inspect the content of a disk of
Commerce 64. I'm going to release this
template I've already released it this
morning and I will give you some more
details at the end of the presentation
about it
okay let's now start in giving some
details about our specimen so our
viruses the virus itself
the virus from what we know existing two
variants which are identified by a
version which is
6.6.13 and 8.32 so we have also major
release for that and both of them are
available to download if you want to I
know have a look to them to tweet or
replicate the analysis or doing
something by yourself you can download
it from
csdbe.dke site
okay but before going into details you
need to set some
common knowledge on Commodore 64
Hardware because it's very important you
will see during the analysis that a lot
of characteristics of the Commerce 64
will be used in the code of the virus
itself and let's start from the main CPU
the main CPU of the common 64 without is
the well-known 6510 CPU which is based
on 6502 which was one of the first very
cheap CPU that were produced in early
80s and probably it's the secret that
gave the start to the home computer
movement it's the CPU were used and on
which is Bay are based most of the home
computer back then Apple II Atari
Commodore and a lot of others so it was
a very cheap CPU doing a lot of things
indicate in case of Commerce 64 one we
had a clock of 4 megahertz 64k of RAM
and 38 kilobytes of floor program for
basic problem combo 64 had a
characteristic special one had also some
additional chipset for managing video
and sound and that's why it became very
popular for gaming mainly but the main
CPU is the exactly the same as all the
other home computer at the the at the
time what's it it is interesting is that
and I learned it doing this research is
that it's still used you can actually
buy one if you want from this site the
form factor is a bit different right now
as you can see but the 6502 and other
variants of the CPU are still existing
are still used as according to the site
and so that's why I'm saying you you are
not wasting your time this morning
looking at this presentation because
because you are going to learn something
very interesting like
Basics on 6502 assembly and that we can
use maybe on your next Automotive
project I don't know if you want to use
the 6502 CPU
and uh okay let's spend a couple of
words about my storage you see that
picture of Commodore 64 before which was
that keyboard with some
ports on that it doesn't any kind of uh
mass storage unit so the mass storage
back then was done in two ways mainly
the cheap one was a tape player which is
awful slow and reliable it was really
probably one of the worst piece of
Hardware ever created in human history
really I remember it as a unusable
mostly
and it was a cheap solution so that's
what I bought for the first time and
then when you start to save some money
you can buy
another piece of value which is a bit
better it's not really a great Hardware
as well but it's a lot better than the
tape which was a disk drive reading the
floppy disk the five inches property
skew none of you ever saw it the black
one the floppy one exactly
and why I'm mentioning this uh this
Hardware because it's a little
less known that the 1541 disk drive had
exactly another 6502 CPU in it a running
code having some memories I'm having
some register this is why I let I told
you to have a look to the register
window before on the emulator the bugger
window because actually you really have
another CPU equal to the one installed
on the main board that means that you in
some way you had a multi-processor
system back then in 1982 because the two
CPU can actually communicate between
them and they can transfer code between
them and execute code at the same time
so it was pretty surprising to
understand that you actually had a
multi-processor system with the main CPU
and the one running on the drive
you can also offload some works on the
CPU of the drive itself it was not so
easy because the connection between the
two systems were was done through a
Serial bus so it was it was low and so
on but it was actually usable and it was
used also by uh legit software let's say
uh like turbo loader which were
programmed to load things and so on
and guess what yes this can be abused by
viruses as well and this is actually
what the bulavarus is going to do and we
will see how in a while but before going
into the details we have I I promised
you a crash course of assembly of 6502
assembly and so we will go very very
briefly at the crash course of two
slides so don't don't be afraid about it
um
let's have a look on how it how to
actually work so we have a few register
in the CPU a lot less than what we
expect from current architectures like
the Intel one let's say where we have a
lot of them and we have basically a
program counter which is more or less
the same as the instruction AP of the
inter architecture and it's pointing to
the current instruction of the of the
processor and then three general purpose
register one is the a which is the which
stands for accumulator and you can store
values in it and then X and Y which are
indexing register so these are three
general purpose register you can use in
your programs and that's all what you
have you has also some stack pointer
pointing to a fixed memory region going
from one zero one zero zero two zero one
FF and then a flag status which holds
the results of comparisons carry and so
on so very basic structure very simple
one but you can see that you can do a
lot of things with this uh and I think
also these slides here regarding the
register zero zero zero one which are
reported by device simulator because
these are out of our scope today they
are registered for the sound interface
device which was one of the the chip I
mentioned before doing for a used for
doing sounds but we don't need them our
analysis today just reporting it is
because of for completeness
and so uh very basic crash course about
assembly so we can basically do some
things with the register we can store
values there and load values from the
register themselves so the instructions
are pretty simple it's a very very
simple instruction set on the 6502 and
you have LDA to load the value in the
accumulator so you can put the value
there you can put an immediate value by
putting a dash before it or a preference
or you can reference a memory address
and on the opposite way you can also
store the value that is in the
accumulator into memory so you have LDA
and SDA at the same time you have ldx
STX and LD and sty and ldy for the same
separate with the same operation with
other two registers it's like the move
operation in
Intel assembly let's say then we have
another instruction which is interesting
for us which is the jsr which is the
basically the same as the call in Intel
architecture with the closer used by an
RTS instruction which is returning to
the calling function and then obviously
we have also some branching instructions
so you can jump around
basically on the results of several
operations and so on so you have this
set of instructions here BPL BMI ebvc
and so on
couple of slides then we can jump into
the bars itself so uh kernel that
strange word it's coming from Commerce
64 era uh what is Kernel it's line it
sounds like it's it has been misspelled
and actually it was it's something like
probably it was mean to be kernel with e
not EA and this is the Commodore 64 ROM
resident operating system call so you
can call some
routings doing basic operation by
calling a specific memory address
compared to the model
s and codes here PC World it's something
like the BIOS OS routing you have we
have in current PC more or less so we
have this way to call Basic and low
level kernel kernel course and then we
have another way of calling more higher
level routings which are the basic ones
which are stored from a0 to bfff
and this this memory area holds the code
for the basic operation so let's say if
you want I want to do a print the code
of the printed stored in this area and I
call it directly by calling the memory
area instead of writing print in my
basic program and that's a way of doing
things in common 64. but let's start now
with our analysis so the Ebola virus
which is which we saw before that it has
been
it's one of the few viruses remained
which were not analyzed yet
okay we need to obviously start it in
some way remember okay I said before the
virus Never Dies so it's just a matter
of giving him the right environment and
it starts again and the other right
environment in our case is the emulator
object and this is what happened when
you start the virus so something strange
actually so you hit this you see this
flashing screen here and some gibberish
printed out on the screen which is and
then nothing happens so uh looks like a
really nothing has been done to the user
but
what happened behind the scene in this
case
so let's start with the some code
Snippets okay this is written really
tiny here but don't worry I will go into
details now so we will see with more
details so what happens
doing these comments or running the
program virus is that the
um
serial bus was opened on the device so
remember that I spoke that the two
processor between CPU and my CPU and the
one on the disk drive communicate
between a Serial bus so this serial bus
has been opened there was an execution
of a command and then there was this
flashing screen and then of course the
bus has been closed so let's see what
really happened here these are the set
of instructions opening the serial bus
as you can see there are a jsr and the
jump instruction point to the kernel do
you remember the the addresses beginning
with FF so these jump and jsr are
pointing to two kernel calls which are
the cores actually used to open the bus
the serial bus to communicate with the
CPU of this 1541
and then there is the execution of a
command the execution of common is
simply sending a couple of uh characters
three characters in this case m-w which
stands for memory right and sending
these commands this character this ASCII
characters or pet task in this case
because comma 64 had a custom ASCII code
sending this and some codes what
happened is that some codes from the
main CPU is transferred to the memory of
the disk drive in this case so what the
virus is done is doing like right now
it's just getting hit code and
transferring it on the
CPU Drive yep
then there is this flashing screen and
the closing why the flashing screen
um back then IO operations were really
slow and you were sometimes really
looking at the screens trying to
understand if something was happening or
not and the flashing screen was a way a
trick used to let the user know that
something was happening during the i o
operation so that's why it has been
added probably in this case so just to
let the user know that something was
happening and then
okay the serial bus is just closed so at
this point what has been done is that
the virus code has been transferred on
the CPU of the floppy but nothing else
so the code has not been executed yet
why this has been done for two reasons
maybe because in this way it's still
here obviously because the the virus
doesn't reside anymore on the main
memory and it's more
it's more persistent right now because
even if power off or reset the common 64
actually until you don't power off the
drive the virus still resides there and
it's not going away so that's a neat way
to gain persistent on the on the call
itself
yep
and so now the virus it's on this drive
memory uh okay it's time to execute it
just to execute it it's just a matter of
sending another command like the MW we
saw before the command it's u3 it's
another command coming from the the ROM
of the 1541 and which exactly just it
just start codes at a very specific
address which is zero five zero zero on
the disk drive since the set of
instructions we sell before was
transferring code to that address the u3
commands is just executing code residing
there so what happens here again
Snippets and we are going into the
details is that the serial bus is open
again there is a u3 common sent on the
serial bus and that means that this the
code starts so the virus itself is
starting on the uh on the disk drive
memory there was a set of commands u3
from u9 executing a code at different
addresses from zero five zero zero to
ff01 it was just a matter of what you
want to do and and execute in this case
and what happens meanwhile on the 1541
obviously there is some code landing at
zero five zero zero where it is where
you have the code waiting for something
and there is just this tiny Loop here
which is just waiting for something it's
waiting for an attention signal to be
coming low and that means that it's
waiting for this activity so the virus
has transferred the code on the drive
and that's just waiting for something to
happen so if the user access the file or
save a file or open one or whatever
again we need to set some other
knowledge about the 1541 disk drive
structure and layout before going ahead
so that you will get the entire virus
life cycle
um okay disks where splitting tracks as
today or less so no difference in with
this floppy disks at 35 tracks in them
with different number of sectors for
each track obviously the smaller trucks
so the internal one where the smaller
end so they had fewer sectors than the
external one which fewer storage
capacity objects
it's a special truck in special truck in
in the 1541 because it holds uh the
information about the disk and which
files are on the disk so are it's the
truck holding the directory it's like
the NF mft and beat mapping and TFS more
or less so uh holding all the
information about the disk
and the special track 18 which is also
12 in hexadecimal as a special
um
um structure as well sectors 1 to 18 of
the directory track contain the
directory entries so all the files
stored on the disks are listed in this
sectors and the real special sector the
sector zero the first one the very first
one which is the bomb the block
availability map which holds the
information about the free and used
blocks on the disks disk itself which is
very important because we will see that
devices will use this information
this is the structure of the sector zero
the bomb okay you see the first two
bytes which are holding okay some data
that are we are not interested in it in
them right now so some generic data but
what is interesting for us it's the byte
4
which holds the number of free sectors
of track one and then the subsequent
um three bytes holding the bitmap of
three sectors on the first track and
then this structure is repeated again
and again and again for all the tracks
of the disk so you have the at byte 8
the number of free tracks for sector two
and then the bitmap of secular the B9 is
just a set of one or zero saying which
blocks are used and which aren't
then all the others so this is for truck
for the sector zero of track 18. then
you have sectors 1 to 18. sectors 1 to
18 are holding the files uh there are
there is uh this kind of structure
repeated for each file and with this
specific structure here you see that the
first two bytes are pointed to the next
one so when the two first two bytes are
zero this is this means that this is the
last file used by the disk itself
then you have very important for a row
analysis it's about starting from zero
two so the third byte and the fourth and
five fifth byte because they are holding
the file type which could be prg SEC
real or USL and the truck and sector
number of the first block of the file
remember this because we will see that
it will be used by wire itself
then there are some other information
like obviously the file name file size
and so on this structure is repeated for
every single file into the camera 64 of
the list of files
I saw you I told you that there are
different file types in Commerce 64. uh
these are the known one so prg sequel
USR handle prgs what is interesting for
us prg is the executable files it's like
a the executable in the modern PC so it
holds code that can be loaded into
memory and the first two bytes of the
file itself are the address where the
program itself is must be loaded
um this is what it actually execute code
then we have also other type of files
which are less interesting for our
analysis but let's just have a quick
look to them
we have a sequential which are just byte
streams byte streams yeah so
um sorry a way to access files to
without a random positioning a RL one
which is a similar way to access files
but with actually a possibility to
position them the the pointer in the
file itself then USA which is a user
defined one and okay that one which is
undocumented undocumented one common 64
also had a basic Integrity file system
and so you had to close the file before
removing the disk and you had also the
possibility to have a star before the
the type of the value if the file is not
being closed in the proper way
now okay we set this knowledge we know
now that which are the information we we
need to
to understand what happens now
and let's start to see what happens when
we try to infect the program starts to
infect the problem itself so we we left
the program waiting for this activity do
you remember
when this activity is recognized okay
there is a start of a specific function
which is the 600600
this function
in which is residing on the 1541 do a
very specific thing so
um it starts to find the first free
Block where on track 18. so on track 12
in hexadecimal so that means the virus
is not trying to store itself in a file
it trines is trying to store itself in
the directory structure which is
something that it should not be done
because the directory structure just
holds file file informations not the
file itself and so it starts counting
from the very end of the
um the the the truck itself and try to
find free blocks there
okay this is just the the way of uh of
doing that it's looping from in the in
the bum so it loads the uh the bomb you
see the block zero here
and then starts looping and looking for
three sectors at the end of the file
white starts from the end of the track
18 because it's more likely to have them
free common 64 these were not known to
be to hold hundreds of files probably
most of them had I don't know 10 25s and
so usually the last three blocks of the
tricketing were actually not used at all
and so it's very likely to have them
free and so the virus is trying just to
check if these three blocks are free
actually and if not it's just try to
move it and look for the one going
through the beginning of the file and it
does it through this Loop here when it
detects three sectors why three Because
the actual the code of the virus itself
it's all it has been all in three
sectors it marked them as used into the
bitmap so it does not write the code
again still but it just mark it Mark the
sector as used
okay now uh
it's the virus itself just found a way
to okay it can stores its code on the
disk but it's not sure yet if it can be
re-executed because
actually the virus itself wants to be
executed in order to infect another
system another disk
and so it starts another loop looking
for a prg file we said before that prg
files were the executable one and so it
starts a loop two
uh uh look for this kind of file you can
see here that it loads the first sector
and then tries to compare for example
you see that it's comparing the
um at the at the very end of the I don't
know if you can point it yeah
there it compare the file type and it
looks for the prg one when it found it
it starts the real infection phase until
then it doesn't so what happens is that
okay I found a prg file back there and
so I want to
a start infection process
what does the infection process it just
get the very first pointer of the of the
program of the prg file and it makes it
pointing to the track 18. so usually
probably the pointer of the file is just
pointing to another track not the
tracking because targeting is not mean
to be to holding some codes and so it
just moved this pointer to the track
itself
and in this way it just
basically try to get be try to be
re-executed when the the user just load
the file
uh there is an additional check so the
the devices also check if the device is
already infected so if we'd find that
the prg file is pointing already to
track 18 which is basically impossible
in a normal situation it just keep the
file and okay it says okay probably it's
already in fact so you can see that
there is there are also error checkings
and so nothing is left to uh the um
with two random things and and so it's
really something that is uh well done in
this case
so it's now time to infect the file
you the device itself it's just getting
the track number for the file itself
it's replacing track and sector number
obviously it replaced the values with
the track and sector truck will be 18
for sure sector will be the sector where
it saves the three blocks he replaced
them so that the prg file will point to
that and then it also makes the very
last block of the of the virus itself
pointing back again to the prg file so
that
the execution of the prg is kept and the
user maybe it does not realize that
there was an infection this
is not really working every time but it
actually worked so let's look up what
actually the infection process is so we
had as we remember the uh on this
activity the loop waiting for on this
activity then okay
when there is a disk activity track it
in has three free blocks yes if yes it
starts the infection process if not just
text it if the prg file then if the
three blocks are free and a PRD file is
found it starts the infection process if
the prg file is not found it does
something like let's say Plan B it's
just rename the disk to boola rules and
it takes it because okay it's just not
trying to do something harmful or doing
something but the system itself but just
exit just renaming the the disk itself
with a new a new name
okay I promised you that we were going
through through the two version of the
virus basically the two versions were
very similar I don't know why there were
two major release between them but okay
the two versions are very similar the
only difference between the two are the
um okay the loading of the version eight
it's a bit stitchier so we don't you
don't have the the flashing screen and
it also hooks the safe command so
um
because addresses for the routings are
saved on zero three zero zero two zero
three FF so just a matter of replacing
that addresses with a new one to
redirect a command in this case the
version 8 is replacing the save Vector
with a reset Vector so that if the user
is typing save to save something it just
got the computer itself reset and then
so everything is cleaned up but you
still have at this point the virus is
residing on the on the code of the sorry
on the CPU of the 1541
a device
okay
I published some tools because this
exercise was done through several tools
but I also
built my own tools for doing this
analysis I hope maybe you can find them
useful also to do some other analysis
about virus malware or maybe just other
programs this is the zero one zero
template editor editor template which
has been built to read and analyze the
disk structure as you can see you can
analyze on the bottom side here the
structure for example of the bomb of the
directory showing up which is the bitmap
of each blocks and so on so it helped me
to analyze what the virus was doing and
it's pretty neat to use for analyzing
disks images of the Commodore 64 itself
then I created a couple of gidra scripts
in order to mapping the code as I said
you the um
analyzer was the the video analyzer was
also the compiling but I mostly used
assembly in this case and these scripts
are just mapping for example all the
kernel and ROM calls for Commerce 64
into this in the source of the assembly
code just adding comments on what the
call is doing so it allows you to
streamline your analysis of the code if
you apply this kind of scripts on
your analysis for example and the same
has been done for the 1541 ROM course
because one five four one had
its additional ROM course the NW common
we saw the u3 common we saw and so on
I'm also published the two database of
the gitter database I created
these are two databases everything is
heavily commented as you can see here
these are the complete analysis of the
two virus sample you can open it with
your guidra and have a look to it if you
want they are it will be available on on
the GitHub as well so just for reference
if you want to have a look
and let's jump to the conclusion so why
uh I decided to do the the this talk
today with you
um
okay we are at the end and we saw that
the fully functional malicious code can
be put in 700 bytes we saw that this is
this was a virus that was completely
functional with a lot of functions with
everything done in the proper way
replication persistence even even some
really nice things like moving itself on
different devices and so on so the
techniques used by the virus were not
new because they were used by legit
software as well so
um
they were they were not discovered by
this virus for sure but it was in any
case interesting to complete this
knowledge because
it was really helpful for me as a
reverse engineer and I I'll tell you
also why okay as I said the scripting
together with the fully commented
Community database are available on my
GitHub and you can download them and
have a look if you want
and let's have a look on what we learned
or what I learned I hope you learned as
well because that's the real core of the
talk from my point of view I mean as I
said I'm a reverse engineer and um
from a reverse engineering point of view
what I learned or let's say record
because sometimes it's just a matter of
recalling things not really learning but
sometimes you can't forget some things
with this analysis that okay for example
if your assembly structure does not mean
that we have few functionality
we saw 700 bytes software doing a lot of
things like replicating writing checking
for errors which is not really something
that you can give for for done even if
higher level programs so that's
something that you have to consider and
that's really interesting for for us as
reverse engineering so it does not mean
that a small program is doing few things
then the other important things that I'm
sure I tend to forget and I think it's a
gray area in the malware analysis
nowadays it said that we don't have to
forget external devices when we are
looking at malicious software
um in this case we saw that we had two
CPUs running on two different devices of
the computer itself right now think
about how many
chips you have in a
model computer
I'm sure that you can tell me that okay
but these are not executing code or you
cannot access directly yeah true but you
have device drivers accessing these kind
of things and think about it think about
the thing that you may misuse a device
driver in order to I don't know execute
code write code store code somewhere
where we are not expected we not we
don't expect to see it we have a lot of
additional things in our systems right
now and so far from what I think is the
this is a kind of a gray area it's not
really explored from what regards the
um demolition software and so something
we need to take into consideration
and then the first thing I learned and I
would like also to pass to you it's the
that the assembly proficiencies opens a
lot of doors I tend to see that
assemblies a bit let's say I forgot
language so it's not teached anymore
nobody is caring about it
uh I don't I'm not saying here that you
have to write your next word processor
in assembly which is not the case
obviously and probably you don't need to
write anything in assembly in most of
the case but it's very important from my
point of view that everybody working in
security knows assembly and knows in a
proper way
because this really opens a lot of doors
from my point of view for example in
this kind of analysis I didn't know the
6502 architecture I learned in doing
this analysis together with youth as
this morning and the fact that I had
knowledge of internal assembly or arm
assembly really streamlined for me the
analysis of this simple architecture so
that's something that we need to keep
into consideration also when we think
about studies of new people coming into
security fields and so on we don't have
to forget that the Assembly Language
it's very important for our purposes
and uh okay so these are all the
references for what I used and what I
was speaking about today I want to leave
these lights some seconds so that
everybody is created in the proper way
and um
okay so I think that um at the end of my
presentation so I just want